news daily from science mission focus in
the journal Nature communications show
that mice treated with amoxicillin and
tyrosine two classes of widely used
childhood antibiotics gained more weight
and developed larger bones than
untreated mice both of the antibiotics
also disrupted the gut microbiome the
trillions of microbes that inhabit the
intestinal tract this highlights the
need for better awareness of the
potential downsides of antibiotic
overuse next the femina has been linked
to decline in male sexual urge during
old age but the mechanism is not known
authors in the journal Nature
communications identify group of
dopamine neurons called proto cerebral
posterior lateral dopaminergic cluster
of neuron to a B that is ppl to a B
regulate male courtship sustainment and
that tyrosine hydroxylase and enzyme
responsible for dopamine synthesis
levels in these cells decline with age
interestingly altering dopamine levels
in specific ppl to a B neurons did not
affect motor activity sensory processing
including smell and taste nor the length
of life suggesting that ppl to a [ __ ]
on specifically regulate male sexuality
for more news visitors at www since
mission calm or science mission Facebook